[Music]
this idea of bricks
um is is an analogy i've been using for
years with my students
because they would come in with deep
anxiety or depression or frustration
and it was always good for them to step
out and say hey what are you carrying
around
into this class because they look around
this classroom and they think man i'm
the dumb one here i'm not as fast here
i'm not the fill in the blank
and i'd say man you're trying to compare
yourself in a sprint race
if you're just staying even you're
carrying around 100 pounds more than the
other guy over there
you're actually faster and stronger than
he is you're just keeping keeping pace
right and so over time i learned more
and more about
this word that's become i guess in vogue
now and thank god it is because we're
having some great conversations
about this idea of trauma right so we
think of trauma about being it's
something like you're in a car wreck or
you go to war
spouse cheats on you apparently sudden
suddenly dies and that's true
right so you have trauma that the nerd
word is acute
i call it big t trauma it's the big ones
right you are a little kid and you're
playing tag
and somebody you you reach out to get
somebody
you know giggling and then all of a
sudden when they hit a wall and break
both wrists and start screaming
um because they're experiencing pain
they've never experienced that's a big t
right that's big t um i've experienced
big t that i'm not gonna talk about on a
on a podcast right that's mine
right um and then there's a a huge
moment for me was with my good friend
lynn jennings dr lynn jennings she's a
trauma researcher
as well as a child counselor in texas
and she helped open my eyes to another
side of trauma which is this what
i'm going to call little t trauma right
it is
cumulative trauma trauma that adds up on
you over time
so if you think about bricks being big t
trauma right you walk home
and you find out that your husband of
seven years is cheating on you
and everything that you were anchored to
is suddenly severed
um or your uncle sexually abuses you and
he's the guy that came over
and um was your babysitter and your
parents trusted him and nobody listened
to you
that's big t trauma that's a cinder
block that goes in your backpack for
for for years right but then cumulative
trauma
is um
when you come down the stairs every
single day and your mom says
oh honey that shirt that shirt makes you
look pudgy and you want to be
you want the boys to like you don't you
want to be a pretty girl pretty girls
aren't pudgy
and you go yeah yeah yeah and you're six
right and so you go back upstairs to
change
that's a little rock that goes in your
backpack every time
every time mom didn't hit you she didn't
throw something at you
but she just said ah you aren't good
enough and you're gonna need to change
and cover a part of you
up so that others will like you others
will think you're valuable
and those i call those little rocks and
they go in your backpack and over time
it's cumulative
little t trauma adds up over time and
suddenly
those same little rocks add up to the
same weight as a cinder block
if you look at a at a public school
teacher has been teaching for 40 years
sometimes they'll
literally walk hunched over a little bit
right
and so one day your counselor pulls you
out of class and says hey your mom
passed away that's big key trauma
right your mom tells you every day
you want to be loved don't you right um
that's a little t it adds up and it adds
up and it adds up and it adds up
and ultimately the weight in the
backpack is the same
right and so when you hear callers on
this show all the time
one of the things i'm always trying to
get to as quickly as possible is what is
that person carrying
what are they carrying that's making
their journey from a to b
harder to get to right so um
here's the deal at the end of the day
these i
i started re-examining my how what i
thought about trauma
and it's informed by peter levine who
will link to these books in the show
notes wrote an extraordinary book
called uh waking the tiger and um
i think that's the title of the books
that's how the book i think that is
it's waking the tiger and the body keeps
the score by
bessel vanderkult and here's what they
they really open my eyes and help expand
my definition of trauma even further
is trauma is not the event that awful
moment
and in fact there's been a lot of
studies on memory that will tell me or
suggest to me that my memories aren't
always so
reliable what is reliable
is that my body sounds all the alarms
it remembers and so trauma i've stopped
defining as what happened
and i've started re-examining my body
for
when does my body set off alarms in the
present
anchored to things in the past trauma is
any time your body responds to a past
situation
as though it's happening in the present
right so vander kulk says that trauma is
much more than a story about the past
that explains
why people are frightened or angry out
of control trauma is re-experienced in
the present
not as a story but as a body reaction
right
so you may experience this when you get
around some
you see some guy and your friend shows
up and like hey this is tom
and your body just goes get out of it
right who knows where that trauma's
setting off you may know
right or when i see kids running and
playing
together in a cafeteria man my heart
starts racing
because my brain has been scanning the
environment for the last 30 years
waiting for that moment
and saying we remember what happens when
we do this
don't do that and so i have to then
go oh those are just kids playing the
chances of that happening again are
basically zero
they're gonna have a good time what i
need to do is address my body
or like a trauma situation we would show
up to a crisis situation where let's say
there
someone had been shot um and people's
bodies were still responding as though
there was an active shooter in that
building what we would do is we would
say hey we need you to be
present now it was scary then you're
okay now you're safe
now right and so we
the analogy is those that traumas those
bricks we carry
and you begin to go through your
backpack and look at these bricks and
examine them
for truth right and so over time of
course your knees hurt and your back
hurts and you have stress headaches you
have all these bodily responses to these
things that happened to you in the past
and it could be as benign as
man you lied and got busted when you
were 14 and you took on the identity of
i'm a liar
i'm just a a a scummy idiot
or it could have been that you were
sexually traumatized as a kid or you
were beat up as a kid
or that coach told you you can do
anything
or that coach told you you're such a
wimp
you'll always be a wimp right and so
ultimately
one of the most important things i think
for folks to get to is to a
you got to know what bricks are in your
backpack you got to unders you got to do
that hard work and finding out what
stories are in there
what stories were you born into what
stories have you told yourself what
stories were told to you
and you got to demand evidence from
those stories you got to look at them
and say is this true
did i lie when i was 14 yes i did did i
play tag with a girl and push her when
she was
9 or 10 and both of her wrists she broke
both of her wrists
i no i might say that i broke them i
shoved her and she hit a wall
that happened yes does that mean that
every time kids play
someone's gonna get hurt no does that
mean i'm a guy that hurts children
no right and so i'm looking at these
bricks and demanding evidence
and then the hard work is actually
setting them
down right so i would want everybody to
start um and i'm in the middle of
writing a book on this
it's become um
somewhat of a connection between
folks that i didn't never anticipated
that
everyone is starting to recognize how
much crap they're carrying around
right and it could be oh i thought all
republicans thought this and i thought
all democrats
hated america and i thought all parents
who
right we just carry these stories these
stories these stories and i also say
this
media often has a vested interest
and you carrying a lot in your backpack
a lot of
identities you are always going to be
nothing more than the worst thing you
ever did
you will always be nothing more than the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
because the more they can keep your
alarms spinning
the more they can sell you a solution
they can offer you
a result and they can offer you
something to make it go away whether
it's
you just need some you time or a new
class or new program or a new
type of therapy whatever and what i want
to tell you is there's another way
and the other way is getting with
people that you care about or that you
trust often with a professional
counselor depending on
the level of trauma that you experience
the big t trauma and even little teacher
i'm as a kid
or as an adult and taking those bricks
out of your backpack and just
setting them down those backpacks get
really really heavy